I just want to make a short statement on
the hostage incident in Martin place in
Sydney New South Wales police are
responding they are being strongly
supported by Commonwealth agencies we
don't yet know the motivation of the
perpetrator we don't know whether this
is politically motivated although
obviously there are some indications
that it could be we have to appreciate
that
even in a society such as ours there are
people who would wish to do us harm
that's why we have police and security
organisations of the utmost
professionalism that are ready and able
to respond to a whole range of
situations and contingencies including
the situation that we are now seeing in
Sydney the whole point of politically
motivated violence is to scare people
out of being themselves Australia is a
peaceful open and generous society
nothing should ever change that
and that's why I would work I would urge
all Australians today to go about their
business as usual of course if anyone
does have any suspicions of untoward
activity there is the national security
hotline 1-800 one two three four hundred
which I would urge them to call I can
let you know that the National Security
Committee of the cabinet has been
briefed on this incident I've been in
regular contact with premier Baird over
the course of the last couple of hours
I've been briefed by Commissioner
Scipione of the New South Wales Police
and by Commissioner Colvin of the
Australian Federal Police this is an
unfolding situation
and as the situation unfolds there will
be operational updates provided by the
New South Wales police I want to assure
people that the ordinary business of
government must go on and it will go on
and that's why treasurer hockey and
finance minister Corman will shortly be
releasing the mid-year economic and
fiscal outlook as planned
finally this is a very disturbing
incident
I can understand the concerns and
anxieties of the Australian people at a
time like this but our thoughts and
prayers must above all go out to the
individuals who are caught up in this I
can think of almost nothing more
distressing more terrifying than to be
caught up in such a situation and our
hearts go out to those people I'm going
to leave it to the New South Wales
Police who are in operational charge of
this incident to provide those kinds of
details obviously in a situation like
this all sorts of reports fly around all
sorts of claims are made so I I do urge
everyone to exercise caution in their
reporting but I will leave all of the
operational details to the New South
Wales Police who as I understand it will
begin providing operational updates
shortly